hello I'm in Maine Maine is a very nice
place Jen and I are starting another
temporary project it's not going to last
very long because it's central focus
isn't going to last very long it's
called Obama's idiots and it is as you
may imagine concerning the 2008
presidential race so to youtube.com
slash Obama's idiots during this project
John and I will be raising money for
Democratic candidates and if we reach
certain goals we will do painful slash
embarrassing things to ourselves slash
myself because I haven't actually got
John to really do this yet but John will
definitely be delivering informative
political commentary and news and I will
definitely be punishing myself in return
for people giving money to Barack Obama
and other Democratic candidates
including Daniel Biss who was the first
candidate that we're doing stuff for
there was a comment left on the Obama
citiots channel saying that of all the
daughters we're gonna be doing this
delivering environmental and Democratic
propaganda they were not going to pay
attention anymore I kind of agree with
the Democratic propaganda like I don't
want that to be what nerdfighting is and
I am a hundred percent in favor there
being Republican nerdfighters but I
don't know if I want anybody here who's
anti environment because being a
nerdfighter is about respect and caring
for people other than yourself it's
about appreciating people for who they
are it's about getting other people
chances and I think that we should
include in that group of people who
we're giving the chance to to be
themselves and they'll give it to the
full potential of who they are I think
that we should be including the people
from the future the people like my kids
and your kids because I think that we
only have one rock to live on and this
rock needs to be protected this year
next year for the next hundred years or
the next millennium we need to make sure
that this is a place where people can
live I don't want my kids to inherit a
poisonous ball of slime environmentalism
isn't about today it's about the future
it's about what we're doing now
affecting the people of the future and
if it's not the most important nation to
you
I completely understand health care is
pretty much just as important if not
more important because it affects me
personally but if you're anti
environment if you want to go out there
and destroy this yeah I don't know that
you can be a nerdfighter if you if
that's your thing if destroying the
world is your thing I think that that's
kind of Toby and I'm Toby and there's a
word that I just made up Decepticon II I
don't know Toby and sounds good
sounds evil Tobin and I hope you don't
mind that I'm thinking that because it's
hard not to think that when you're in
somewhere as beautiful as this place is
so that's all I have for you today from
this beautiful day on the Maine coast
and I am going to get some ice cream
John I will see you later